let's start with DreamWorks very first
animated feature ants the controversial
predecessor to a bug's life the Disney
thing the idea first to Katzenberg blah
blah blah blah blah who cares let's just
look at the movie as a whole the film
stars an aunt named Z played by Woody
Allen
he's a surprise a neurotic living in a
colony of ants where it's very easy to
lose your identity he has friends here
and there but for the most part he finds
it hard to bend it that is until he
accidentally comes across the Queen's
daughter played by Sharon Stone which is
weird because yeah they're all
technically her children but I guess
somehow they singled her out as princess
because she's being trained to carry the
children neck don't know how it works
but they have a romance and seem to hit
it off but while uncovering an evil plan
from a general land played by Gene
Hackman Z and the princess get whisked
away outside of the colony and lusts the
two are on a hair-raising adventure
against humans other insects and even
their own kind to find what they call
paradise known as insectopia which is
really nothing more than a garbage can
as a first film this is pretty damn good
from an animation company the CG now is
a touch dated but when it came out it
was pretty impressive I find interesting
that I actually don't have a hard time
telling the ants apart they're not drawn
like typical cartoon characters with big
eyes or big expressions but somehow I
actually do know which ones are which
part of that comes from the incredibly
distinct voices that they have yeah this
movie really krantz the celebrities in
there I mean there's a ton but to its
credit they all sort of fit
Woody Allen as the neurotic that's a
no-brainer gene Hackman's the bad guy
that works obviously Stallone is a
soldier obviously fits well Jennifer
Lopez is one of the tough miners that
works - Danny Glover has a supportive
comrade dan Aykroyd has a snobby
sophisticate these actually really do
fall together that is all except for one
what the hell is Christopher Walken
doing in this movie and I'm not at all
about the Christopher Walken hate
anything he's in I'll take it but I why
he has like no role he's the assistant
to the general
and that's it there's no other character
to him he's not weird he's not strange
and his voice sticks out like a sore
thumb imagine
strong colony sir colony we can be proud
of
I just remembered snickering the whole
time cuz every time he opened his mouth
I'd be like oh that's Christopher Walken
and he sounds funny I wish she was given
funny stuff to do but well around the
subject the film is pretty funny I mean
okay not knee-slapping funny but it
certainly does great in creating these
grand environments made out of everyday
small things their view of the world and
the way they actually act as a colony is
pretty entertaining literally at Birth
they decide whether or not they're gonna
be a worker or a soldier and of course
there's a lot of obvious commentary and
either following the pack or being an
individual and where you draw the line
which is why I think the film really
does work better for maybe a younger
audience I remember when I saw this I
was a junior in high school I was going
through my rebellious artist phase and
this is just the movie I want to see not
realizing that a bajillion movies more
that year in the following years we're
going to come with a very similar
message that's not a bad message it's
just kind of been hammered to death in
other films and yeah this one kind of
hammers into death too but what makes it
stand out is the characters the
environments they create and the fact
that while it's animated it doesn't go
totally kid-friendly
I mean yeah kids can watch it I said I
enjoyed it in high school but the
designs aren't as colorful or baby
friendly as something like Pixar TV
neither is the story of a Content for
that matter and I think that gives a
little bit more of an edge even the bad
guys diabolical plan at first I thought
was kind of cliched what he just wants
to wipe out the weak start all over and
have a survival of the fittest type
thing but when you really look at the
way they set up this colony and the way
things work yeah actually you can see
how a character like that would before I
even give credit to the fact that the
bugs are not all the same size like in a
bug's life everything is actually to
scale the termites are much bigger
mantises are much bigger bees are much
bigger it's like yeah bugs aren't all
the same size and that makes for much
more entertaining and threatening world
to go through so I really like the film
doesn't have flaws sure is the message a
little passe a touch
but I think it still stands out as being
a very unique tongue-in-cheek adventure
and audiences at the time seem to like
it too but this would turn out to be
only the first big hit and DreamWorks is
aligned
you